hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason io
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
this is a little bit old-timey language
when you're making moral decisions
and talking about them with your friends
family co-workers you don't often say to
yourself things like the principle by
which i am deciding the case is as
follows
that's more you know victorian type
language but you do use principles you
say well here's my way of seeing it
here's what i think matters here's
here's my um
criterion for judging this sort of thing
here's why i think this ought to be done
that way that means you're appealing to
some sort of principle
some sort of starting point for your
reasoning for your practical reasoning
of what to do in this particular case
benefit is indicating this principle of
utility like we said what is the
principle of utility it judges
actions based on
whether they have a tendency to produce
the greatest happiness for the greatest
amount of people that is to maximize
happiness minimize pain
it looks at pleasure as being the good
pain as being the bad and it looks at it
for everybody that's the principle of
utility also called the greatest
happiness principle not so much by
bentham but more by later utilitarians
like milk
is that the only way people make
decisions
no
bentham talks about three other
principles by which people might decide
this one of which he thinks is not
actually a real principle it boils down
to other things
the principle of asceticism he says is
always opposed to the principle of
utilitarianism or principle of utility
what is asceticism do you guys remember
that that term
if somebody's ascetic yeah
yeah now that's that's the possible way
to look at it asceticism is
self-discipline how do people who don't
like asceticism
think about it they use that word self
and then they
they add another term to it
they're disciplined starts with a d as
well
what's that
that's okay
self-denial if you're an aesthetic
you
deprive yourself of of pleasures
why i mean there could be all sorts of
agreements that's okay don't worry about
it
um
there could be all sorts of reasons like
i'm not worthy of pleasure i don't
deserve anything
some people aren't sonic in that way
other people i can't trust myself if i
if i allow myself to indulge in this
pleasure if i eat just one of the trucks
i need a whole box so i can't have any
chocolate
or
you know if i'm in you know alcoholics
anonymous i'm not supposed to have any
drinks right why because if i have one
then i can't stop myself
on more if i'm a gambler i can't go to
the slot machine because the slot
machine is going to leave me on the
poker table and to destitution and you
know
maxing out my credit cards and that sort
of thing right um
some people just seem to be
of the mindset that pleasure by itself
is a bad thing
you know prudish people you guys know
some people like this they see somebody
else having fun they're like they
shouldn't be having fun
that's not a good thing
they should be working or they should be
you know praying or they should be
doing something else right there there's
also you know
there's there's all sorts of um
ways of being a set
and you know christian monks out in the
desert they were aesthetic what was
their purpose
um you know was it just to be just to
deprive themselves of everything
kind of a dumb reason to go out in the
desert you know given the chance to
actually live in the city
they wanted to be closer to god right
yeah they thought that depriving
themselves of pleasures was going to be
a good way to do that but they were
actually looking forward to a greater
pleasure down down the way
um
if you're an athlete you have to be kind
of aesthetic right you can't do anything
that you like
why what's the what's the purpose there
you want to win right you want to
succeed
and um if you're even if you're not an
athlete in the sense of a competitive
athlete you're just training like you
want to be in the marathon you want to
you know you want to have that good
feeling that comes with that but during
that time you have to stop
uh
eating what you like and drinking what
you like and staying up as late as you
want and you have to go out and run even
though it's you know raining and cold
and force yourself to endure something
something like that so you know some
people are ascetic because they want to
pay off in something else some people
actually get in the mindset where
pleasure is bad pain is good
and if they hold that position then
they're adopting the principle of
asceticism
bentham thinks that that's
basically when it comes down to it
insane
you know he doesn't give an awful lot of
argument about it he says look if you if
you actually have the mindset that
pleasure is a
genuinely bad thing you've got to say
why it's bad
and if you're a reason why it's bad is
because it's shameful well then you're
really still worried about some sort of
pleasure you're just like contrasting
pleasures of reputation against
pleasures of
the body
or if it's success that you you want you
know you're going to be
very disciplined and not allow yourself
any pleasures because you want to be
rich when you're 40.
really what you want is to be rich and
you're going to take pleasure in that
you're just you know deferring those
pleasures for right now so you really
you're not that psychic and if you are
truly aesthetic and you think that pain
is a good thing and pleasure's a bad
thing there's not much more talking to
be done by a utilitarian you're just
nuts
you would say
um
what about this other principle sympathy
and antipathy now we don't use antipathy
that that often what is sympathy if
you're sympathetic to somebody yeah
feel bad for them yeah
you sympathize means you feel with them
and the way that bentham is using this
is a little bit different from that
he says that it is based on feeling
and it's almost like not having a
principle at all
because if you're judging on the
principle of sympathy and antipathy you
look at an action and you say
how do i feel about that action do i
like it do i dislike it if i dislike it
it's a bad action if i like it it's a
good action you can do this with people
too you know um
i like
people with uh
hair that's i guess i'd call that sort
of wandish
yeah
brownish blonde is kind of hard to tell
so i don't like the dark-haired people
just the the lighter people so i don't
like him
and i don't like him because he's got
some hair but i do like him and i like
her and her
and so the things that they do are good
and the things that they do are bad
that's kind of silly isn't it we could
just as easily reverse it i like the
dark haired people so what you do is
good and what you do is good
and what you do is bad
or i like everybody except for the ones
who
you know have birthdays on
odd number of days
i don't even know which ones of you i
like or don't like but i'm sure there's
some of you that have birthdays on odd
days
and once i find out
i'll judge you for that that's that's
what bentham is talking about with this
principle of sympathy and integrity
it can be a lot more sophisticated than
that it can rationalize itself in all
sorts of ways but ultimately it boils
down to personal feeling it's very much
like emotivism remember when we talk
about motivism it's just a matter of
preference that's all there is
and that's the way a lot of people do
make decisions
sometimes that will actually be in line
with the principle of utility because it
will tell you
hey this is a good decision but it will
tell you that for the wrong reasons
the fact that i like it or i don't like
it is not really a good reason if i'm
utilitarian for deciding an action is
right or wrong i should be using the
principle of utility and looking at how
it positively or negatively affects
people the last thing that he talks
about you notice you're going to see
this a lot in his works he brings up
religion right why why do you think he
talks so much about religion and then
talks a little about it
why does he always mention religion
think about when he's writing
he's writing in the late 1700s early
1800s
most people were at least professing to
be religious back then right
most people had some sort of practice
religion was often seen as sort of
intrinsically connected with morality
so you know if you were writing a
treatise about morals you would have to
address religion to a certain degree
so why doesn't he why does he say
something like the theological principle
is not really a principle
or when he talks about the religious
sanction it's not really
a sanction on its own
benjamin thinks that religion just boils
down to
other things
so
when we're talking about
pleasures and pains you know there's
what he called the pleasures and pains
of piety
those are you know thinking whether god
likes or doesn't like your actions
so if you think that god
you know exists and god takes an
interest in your actions and god thinks
some things are good and god thinks
other things are bad then you're gonna
you know feel worried if you do a bad
action
and that'll produce a certain pain on
your part if you do good actions you'll
feel happy because you figured god you
know is happy with my my behavior
but really that comes down to the
principle of utility
unless god's a jerk
or perverse
because god presumably would actually
prevent them
see that this is the right way to judge
things and so god would want you to do
things like
what feed the hungry
hold the naked
visit those in prison
comfort those who are afflicted why
because god wants you to produce a
greater balance of pleasures over pains
for the community in general so you
don't really need a theological
principle
you can just turn that into utility if
on the other hand you think that god
wants you to suffer
if that's your view of god god's this
mean guy up in the sky who we don't
really understand anything about he
wants us to have a
terrible time
down here
then you're really just using the
principle of asceticism
and if you don't if your view of god is
god's just kind of whimsical does
whatever he wants does whatever it wants
some things are good some things are bad
there's no rhyme or reason for it
principle of uh sympathy and antipathy
you guys see how all these different
principles
work for bentham he's advocating this
one
he's attacking these other two and he's
saying this one
it just boils down to one of these other
three